[Music]
do you recognize this boy metro police
are hoping someone does after his body
was found in a forest outside of town
a hiker made the discovery on state
route 160 between las vegas and parum
right near mountain springs sasha loftis
joining us live from metro police
headquarters with more
on detectives call to the public tonight
sasha
brian the story isn't just sad it's also
still a mystery
detectives say this child was clearly
the victim of a homicide
but they say this investigation can't
continue until they figure out
who he was i never seen anything like
i've seen today
a quiet day takes a devastating turn
after one disturbing discovery i mean
children
you know that's just bad all the way
around neighbor larry barlow shares
what he saw after a child's body was
found here
near mountain springs off state route
160 between
las vegas and pahrump on friday
everything that we can do we are doing
this is what police say he looks like
metro homicide lieutenant ray spencer
describes the boy as hispanic
about 10 years old 4 foot 11 and just
over 120 pounds
it's paramount that we're able to
identify him so we can begin
the the key points of this investigation
but quite a few questions remain after
scouring southern nevada databases
detectives say no missing children match
his description
that's where the public's help comes
into play someone has to
recognize this young man it could be a
neighbor it could be
a friend of the family any tip or clue
can shed light on this entire case
and bring closure to this kid his life
and to anyone who loved him that's
really sad
detectives believe the child has been
dead for about 24 hours or so
they won't release how he exactly he
died or what injuries he had
but they do ask you if you know anything
to please call
metro homicide you should see that
number here on your screen 702-828-3521
you can also call crime stoppers to
remain anonymous
reporting live tonight sacha loftis 8
news now